bien estamos en el problema 14 así que
vamos a empezar de una vez con este
problema y tengo un plan que anciano así
que vamos a hacer el plan o casiano a
que tengo aquí tengo un eje algo más o
menos así ok y tengo a mi otro eje por
acá me andan estos problemas del de 7
cada vez lo siento más divertidos y cada
vez lo siento un poco estén más
elaborados recuerdos los vídeos les ya
te los que tenemos en un principio pues
bueno en cada vez creo que estos vídeos
les aten se están poniendo más
interesantes estamos el problema número
14 aclaró y tenemos una función lineal
tenemos una línea recta parecida a ésta
más o menos así y por cierto nos dicen
que esta recta pasa por aquí que es el
valor déjenme cambiar de color que es el
valor de uno de menos uno y por este
valor que es el valor de menos tres a
menos tres en x ok y lo que me dicen es
que si ésta es nuestra recta base cual
las siguientes gráficas representa mejor
la función que es igual a menos 3 m más
b lo que quiero encontrar es la gráfica
de esta función si yo tengo que m ibm
son la pendiente y la ordenada el origen
de esta gráfica esta gráfica que tengo
aquí tiene como ecuación y es igual a m
x + b y bueno lo padre de esta ecuación
es que de una manera muy rápida podemos
encontrar el valor debe ver vale y es la
orden dada al origen es decir donde
cortamos al eje de las guías y cortamos
al decir las 10 en el valor de menos 1
por lo tanto y es igual a m x menos 1 ya
sabemos que vale menos 1 porque es donde
cortamos al eje de las 10 ahora cómo
podemos encontrar la pendiente estás de
acuerdo que aquí necesitamos una orden
era el origen bueno eso ya lo tenemos de
vale menos 1 voy a buscar
- 3 m x x
y ojo aquí me faltó la equis de ponerla
por aquí vamos a abordar esto de aquí
para poner la x entonces déjenme borrar
esto y vamos a escribirlo bien menos 3 m
por x más b pero bien ya sabemos que
vale menos 1 en esta gráfica y también
en mi otra gráfica va a valer menos 1
ahora lo que necesitamos es el valor de
m tras lo que vamos es el valor de n y
como podemos encontrar a m bueno pues
los padres que tenemos otro punto justo
aquí estamos en el punto menos
30 por lo tanto qué te parece si
sustituimos este punto en nuestra
ecuación
original en esta ecuación de aquí es
decir que cuando el yerbal es 0 x vale
menos 30 es igual a m por menos tres a
menos uno ok sustituir a ye por cero y x
por menos tres y de aquí voy a obtener
que
pero es igual a menos 3m -1 y si quieres
despejar de aquí a m puedo pasar este
uno del otro lado sumando y va a quedar
que menos 3 m es igual a 11 positivo
sume uno de ambos lados de esta ecuación
y si ahora quiero pasar este 3 del otro
lado de la ecuación detuviese es dividir
a ambos lados entre menos 3 me va a
quedar que la pendiente es igual a 1
entre menos tres a uno entre menos tres
o dicho otra manera al menos un tercio
la pendiente es menos un tercio y ya
tengo la ecuación de esta recta esta
recta tiene como ecuación jeff es igual
a menos un tercio de x menos uno esta es
la ecuación de mi recta de color de
color amarillo que tengo aquí ya está lo
podemos corroborar recuerda que la
pendiente es lo mismo que el cambio en
comparado con el cambio en x eso quiere
decir que cuando nosotros subimos uno en
james subimos uno en día estamos aquí
nos movemos tres hacia la izquierda
23 y llegamos justo este punto de aquí
estamos bien entonces tengo que james es
igual a menos un tercio de x menos uno y
ahora ya tengo la pendiente de la
pendiente vale menos un tercio que te
parece si la sustituimos justo aquí para
obtener la ecuación de la gráfica que
estoy buscando y me va a quedar bien es
igual a menos tres menos tres por m pero
me vale menos un tercio esto por x menos
uno o dicho otra manera en la ecuación
que estoy buscando es igual a james es
igual a menos tres por un tercio de
estos dos semanas y me queda solamente x
menos uno recuerda que estos 12 vamos
porque son inversos multiplicativos
menos x menos me da más y 3 por un
tercio es 1 es decir que ahora quiero
buscar la gráfica de la función y es
igual a x menos
y si te das cuenta ésta es una función
que corta al eje de la siesta en el
punto menos 1 estamos justo aquí y
después tenemos una pendiente de 1 es
decir que si nosotros últimos 1 en jeff
vamos a caminar 1 en x estamos por aquí
también pasamos por este punto y si ya
tenemos dos puntos podemos darnos la
idea puede modificar esta recta que
tengo justo aquí esta recta es la recta
que estábamos buscando la recta que es
igual a x menos 1 y si te fijas en todos
los incisos la única que se parece a
esto la única que se parece a esto es el
inciso d por lo tanto mi respuesta es el
inciso d tengo una pendiente de 1 es
decir que por cada uno que nosotros
caminemos a la derecha vamos a caminar
uno en james lo que caminemos en la
derecha lo vamos a caminar hacia arriba
y además tengo que corta al eje de las
10 en menos uno perfecto ok aquí es el
problema número 14 vamos ser problema
número 15 problema número 15 y dice si
el volumen de el cubo es de 8 unidades
el volumen de un cubo es de 8 unidades
cuál es la longitud del centro del cubo
hasta la base del cubo ok esto me parece
bastante bastante interesante
es más podemos estar figurarnos aquí el
cubo tengo aquí mi cara de este cubo y
después tengo una cierta profundidad
algo como por acá
imagínate que este es un cubo que tiene
una un volumen de 8 unidades ahora sí
este cubo tiene un volumen de unidades
lo que sabemos es que cada uno de sus
lados
o cada una de sus aristas me es lo mismo
esta lista mide x es también x ésta mide
x o dicho otra manera para encontrar el
volumen de este cubo tendremos que
multiplicar x x x x x o x al cubo pero x
al jugo es lo mismo que 8 esto es lo que
me dice este problema que el volumen
vale 8 por lo tanto de aquí podremos
despejar cuánto mide cada uno de los
lados de éste
a x es igual a qué número multiplicado
por sí mismo tres veces me da 8 bueno
creo que lo sabemos muy bien es 2x es
igual a 2 por lo tanto tenemos un cubo
déjame ponerlo que otra vez tengo un
cubo pero este cubo tiene cada uno de
sus lados con dos unidades tengo este
cubo de aquí ok
algo así algo por acá y después solo se
unen y cada uno de sus lados mide 2
22 unidades
ahora lo que me preguntan es cuál es la
longitud del centro del cubo hasta la
base del cubo vamos a fijarnos en el
centro en un plano que corte al cubo
justo a la mitad aunque te parece si me
tomo este plano lo va a cortar justo a
la mitad entonces va a llegar como por
acá
así después va a llegar hasta acá hasta
acá y hasta acá tengo un plano que corta
el cubo justo a la mitad si nos fijamos
en este plano vamos a verlo aquí tengo
este plano que corta el cubo justo a la
mitad entonces cada uno de los lados de
este plano mide dos unidades porque
justo en eso quedamos esto mide dos
unidades esto mide dos unidades esto me
de las unidades etcétera y aquí está el
centro del cubo aquí está el centro del
cubo y lo que me preguntan es cuál es la
longitud del centro del cubo es decir
justo aquí hasta llegar a la base del
cubo nosotros nos fijamos en la base de
este cubo pues sería algo más o menos
como por aquí esta sería la base de este
cubo y entonces lo que quiero es cuánto
hay del centro a esta base es decir lo
que me voy a fijar es en esta parte de
acá abajo y para llegar del centro a
esta parte de acá abajo pues bueno esto
es muy fácil como el centro está justo
en la mitad entonces la distancia que
hay aquí acá debe de ser uno de
distancia que hay de aquí acá también
debe de ser uno por lo tanto la longitud
que hay del centro
la base es una unidad es una unidad y
creo que realmente hicimos muchos
dibujos porque el problema estaba muy
fácil la respuesta es el inciso am que
es una unidad okay problema número 15
que subo fácil aunque me gusta mucho
verlos de manera visual y utilizar
colores para que se vea mucho más fácil
la solución del problema
ahora vamos a pensar en el problema
número 16 borremos todo esto y vamos a
hablar del problema el número 10 y 6 ok
vamos con problemas fáciles el problema
16 dice lo siguiente si ye es igual a 5
veces x pública / zeta
en cuanto aumenta jeff si duplicamos x y
duplicamos z es decir vamos a duplicar
duplicar tanto x como zeta a x y y ceta
ok y lo que me preguntan es en cuánto
crece y ahora hay muchas formas de hacer
esto pero como estamos contra tiempo y
para no quebrar nuestra cabeza qué te
parece si le ponemos un valor a esta
función
de equis y de zeta sustituimos vemos
cuánto vale
y después duplicamos xy duplicamos eta
es decir que si nos fijamos en esta
función y le ponemos a x no sé el valor
de 1 se me ocurre de aceta y también del
valor de 1 para no hacernos la vida más
complicada cuánto valdría james bueno
pues yo sería igual a 5 por 1 elevado al
cubo entre 1 lo cual por cierto de 5 ok
cuando x vale 1 y 7 vale 1 en esta
función original ya vale 5 ahora lo que
me pide el problema es que dupliquemos x
y dupliquemos z entonces cuánto va a
valer james si x vale el doble de uno es
decir 2
iceta vale el doble de 1 es decir 2
bueno pues en este caso yo me quedaría
igual a 5 por 2 al cubo entre 2 y esto
es lo mismo que 5 por 8 justo hace rato
habíamos visto que 2 al cubo es lo mismo
que 8 entre 2 y esto es lo mismo que 5
por 4
20 unidades ok pero lo que me piden no
es que me den la respuesta sino es
cuánto aumenta james si nosotros
duplicamos xy duplicamos z y si te das
cuenta lo que hicimos fue pasar de 5 a
20 y bueno esto de una manera aritmética
nos podemos dar cuenta que lo que
hicimos fue aumentar la respuesta a un
patrón es decir multiplicamos por cuatro
el resultado inicial para llegar al
resultado final y justo esta es la
respuesta tenemos un factor de 4 estamos
multiplicando por cuatro el resultado y
esto nos da el inciso en plateau
complica es la vida seguramente cuando
tú ves ese tipo de problemas y piensas
en duplicar xy duplicar z dices bueno a
x lo voy a pasar a 2x y hace tan lo voy
a pasar a 12 está y voy a ver que me da
pero recuerda que estamos en un problema
contratiempo y es mucho mejor y yo te
recomiendo que utiliza es mejor un caso
particular mi consejo es que te tomes un
caso particular
esto en el caso del problema número 16
recuerda que lo que necesitamos es un
vigor en la velocidad del problema pero
ahora estamos en el problema número 10 y
7 y por cierto yo creo que va a ser el
último de este vídeo que me dice daniel
compra un celular por 5 mil pesos
entonces compra un celular por 5 mil
pesos y si el precio del celular decrece
al 20 por ciento anual esta presión va a
decrecer va a decrecer en un 20 por
ciento anual ok el valor del celular de
n es decir a el valor
que depende de nn supongo que esta
cantidad de años
ok después de n años de esta compra está
dado por y me dicen una ecuación muy
importante que es cinco mil cinco mil a
esto no multiplican por cuatro quintos
por cuatro quintos y esto a su vez está
elevado a la n y tienen todo el sentido
de lógico del mundo fíjate que estos
cuatro quintos representan el 80 por
ciento de lo que me queda del valor
original de la compra del celular ok y
después dice cuántos años después de la
fecha de compra tendrá que pasar para
que celular valga 3200 pesos es decir yo
lo que quiero es saber a n la cantidad
de años para que este teléfono valga
3200 pesos es decir que 3200 debe de ser
igual a 5.000 por cuatro quintos por
cuatro quintos elevado a la n algún año
y yo lo que quiero saber es cuántos años
han pasado después de la compra para que
el precio del celular valga 3200 así que
qué te parece si de aquí despejamos a nm
y para despejar a él lo primero que voy
a hacer es pasar este 5000 del otro lado
dividiendo o dicho otra manera dividir
todo entre 5000 y me va a quedar que
3200 entre 5000 entre 5000 esto es igual
a 400
elevado a la n para alguna cierta n y lo
padre es que estos 0 se cancelan este
será con este este se va con este y me
queda solamente 32 entre 50 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que cuatro quintos
elevado a la n ahora 32 entre 50 se
puede reducir un poco tiene mitad
entonces vamos a reducirlo lo más que se
pueda a la mitad de 32 es 16 y la mitad
de 50 es 25 es decir que 32 sobre 50 es
exactamente lo mismo que 16 sobre 25 y
esto a su vez es igual a cuatro quintos
elevado a la n para alguna y ya está ya
te diste cuenta
16 es lo mismo que 4 elevado al cuadrado
y 25 es lo mismo que 5 elevado al
cuadrado es decir que déjame ponerlo así
16 entre 25 es lo mismo que cuatro
quintos elevado al cuadrado que esto a
su vez tiene que ser igual a cuatro
quintos elevado a la n lo que queríamos
saber era n pero de aquí ya puedo
obtener el valor de n n es igual a 2
estos 2 deben de ser iguales para que se
cumplan esta igualdad en deben ser
igualados y entonces podemos construir
que deben de pasar dos años desde la
compra del celular para que el teléfono
valga 3200 pesos y esa es la respuesta
de este problema me he quedado sin
tiempo así que los siguientes tres
problemas y últimos de esta sección lo
resolveremos en el siguiente vídeo hasta
la próxima